acadia les relations entre emmanuel
macron et les journalistes ne sont pas
sans plein et non en effet elles sont
tendues un se souvient de cette phrase
cinglante d'emmanuel macron les
journalistes ne m'intéresse pas mais au
delà notre profession se heurte à des
entraves à la liberté d'informer je vais
citer l'adoption de lois comme la loi
contre les fausses informations la loi
sur le secret des affaires et la
création d'une d'un conseil de
déontologie dans notre profession
ils sont censés empiéter en fait sur la
loi de 1881 qui régissait jusqu'ici
notre profession et qui convenait à tout
le monde
on doit aussi noter que pendant le nu
mais le mandat d' emmanuel macron et
bien huit journalistes ont été entendus
par la dgsi pourquoi parce qu'ils
avaient fait des révélations sur le
pouvoir
on doit noter également nos problèmes
sur le terrain lorsque nous couvrons les
manifestations nous sommes parfois
rudoyé ou interpellés par les forces de
l'ordre ça nous arrive à nous aussi
et puis rsf recensé douze journalistes
blessés par les forces de l'ordre depuis
le rassemblement
le premier les premiers rassemblements
dès gilet jaune en conséquence de quoi
eh bien la france a dégringolé à la 32e
place dans le classement mondial de la
liberté de la présence qui est assez
étonnant pour notre pays
ensuite nous allons aborder la question
de nos rapports avec la présidence là la
question du rap en rt france vous savez
qu'ils sont un peu compliquées ces
relations ça a démarré durant la
campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron avait estimé qu arte
france et spoutnik et un autre média
russe avait agi comme des organes d'un
fluence et de propagande et bien depuis
tout ce temps les rapports ne se sont
pas améliorées nous sommes toujours
interdite d'accès
l'elysée ça signifie que nous n'avons
pas accès aux conférences de presse mais
en répercussion également pas d'accès
aux minister et pas des succès à la
plupart des institutions publiques
et puis les députés aient l'air om en
général refuse de nous parler alors
puisqu'on en est à l'heure des voeux on
pourrait souhaiter qu'en 2020 il vient
cette discrimination envers notre chaîne
c'est ce qu'a technique depuis à l'ailé